the statistic talks about 30 percent of
the world population suffer from some
kind of a sleep disorder
from my point of view with all the
people that I talked with I think it's
much higher so I do believe that this
field is is amazing field and there are
so much that we can do in the field we
know that it's important stage of our
life
we know that there are so many that we
can do through our sleep both for
diagnosis and treatment but we are
lacking good health and the fact that we
bring this kind of stuff for me it's
super exciting and we we are just the
beginning of this journey
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders I
am with ziv perriman neuroscientist and
business leader in the field of digital
Health he is the CEO and co-founder of X
roads a medical device company bringing
Wireless medical grade Monitoring
Solutions to the comfort of users home
environments prior to co-founding
extrodes zif served as vice president of
Medical Solutions at a leading company
in the field of brain health he was also
the CTO of the brain stimulation and
monitoring toolbox Consortium an
experienced business leader with a
diverse background zivas fascinated by
the potential for harnessing deep Tech
into applicable solutions that can
improve health and quality of life he
holds a PhD in neurocognitive science
and a BSC in physics and philosophy both
from Tel Aviv University
thank you very very much for spending
this time with me I'm excited to dive in
with you into this whole world of
medical devices and medicine and and the
startup scene and sensing where
Terrible's home all of those you know
keywords combined and pretty you know
just checking cutting your website
scrolling through it it's really really
cool it almost feels even a little
futuristic and I'm sure that there's a
lot of interesting insights as to the
journey and what you're trying to
develop here that will unravel over
these 20 minutes so again thank you very
much for being here Z tell me a little
bit about your your own passion for for
medicine and medical devices where is
this where's this whole thing coming
from
I I think that the person start
with science
so I started
my PhD
in cognitive neuroscience
and I was studying the neural correlates
of consciousness
and I was super excited from this
opportunity
to learn about ourselves about our mind
our consciousness
and it was an amazing adventure for me
but once I complete my I completed my
PhD
I felt that something is missing
it's amazing pure science
but I felt that I I need something more
applicative
and for me it was like the natural shift
to take all the
knowledge tool experience methodologies
that I used during my PhD
and to shift the focus into more
applicative field where we can actually
can harness all this knowledge and tools
in order to affect people's life so I
think this is the basic like the
starting point to my adventure in the
field of medical and medical devices
now when you take research or research
like behavior and you transition it to
more applicative side well what does
that look like when well what are the
maybe the challenges of doing something
like that
so basically
we use exactly the same tools and
methodologies similar to what we do with
in pure science
but when you try to take it to the
applicative side I think one of the most
challenging uh
stages
is to find or to first of all understand
that you are not
interested in
small effects for example if you will
open most of the journals that you have
in in many different
field there is a trillion you'll see
that you have like all kind of
significant effect between groups and
sometimes it's slightly it's
almost a very small effect but
significant
however when you move to the medical
field and when you would like to get to
the patient and you would like to
something that you will actually make
a change
you you start to to deal with the reward
and then you need more robust effect
and then you understand that you can
treat patients as an average but you
need to to
treat each patient but even by himself
so you start to talk about personalized
effect so it's actually different way of
thinking about science
so I think the the the first challenge
is to understand that you start to walk
whisper with personal life a statistic
and not with a group
and of course then you start to
understand that even if you have the
most amazing technology and unbelievable
innovation
there is still a huge
value or user is a long way until you
can actually use it for medical use and
there are so many other factors in order
that it actually makes change
very very cool tell me about X codes
well what are you guys doing and what
did you decide to focus your applicative
energy on
so we develop a medical grade verbal
solution it's called a skin patch
that you attached to your skin at the
measure your physiology signal
the problem today that in order to
measure many of your physiology signals
like the heart the muscle and the Brain
you need to use a technology is it
called either EEG EMG or refugee
these sensor or rigid electrodes that
you connect your body which gel
something with paste you need to shave
part of your body it's taken a lot a lot
of time to set it up and a lot of walls
and in many cases the only way to
measure it is within the hospital in a
clinic in a lab
and although it's very important tool
for diagnosis of monitoring many
disorders
the only way to get a good signal a good
result is to do it in within the clinic
so we
took actually I I met my co-founder
professorien hanin she she is from Tel
Aviv University she's a ward expert in
the field of human machine interface and
she developed very unique way
way to set for sensors that can measure
your body
without any gel they are flexible and
soft you can attach it to the skin after
four days and it give you
stimulus results like what you have
today in the clinic
so it give us a new era of what you can
measure
out of the hospital
so all kinds of disorders like Sleep
disorders
epilepsy pregnancy and risk and many
other disorders that today use
electrophysiology
and you were limited to Clinic only
today is our new boundaries that the
nurse to go outside to a natural
environment to measure that your own bed
at home
mom so tell me a few simple use cases
for where this may be applicative
because understand the pretty clear
differentiation from the common
wearables that we have today like you
know our Apple watches or the aura ring
Etc and I I'm assuming that it started
from the phrase medical grade that you
use in the beginning of the conversation
what are some use cases in which this
would be relevant for consumers at home
so uh first of when you mentioned all
these solution
that are very good solution but as you
mentioned are when a solution and you
can driven clinical decision based on
this tool
got it and there are solutions uh
that you can measure all kind of subset
of what we can measure in the clinic but
none of them give us a full replacement
of what you have in the clinic
so our first application is slip
monitoring
so basically we provide a solution that
could
change or could replace
what you measure today within the clinic
it's called polysonography it's a slip
study it's a to spend a day you you
spend the night in a slip Clinic
connected to the 30 electrodes and get
the result several days after so
basically we provide this full test at
home
and although
there are some solution medical grade to
measure sleep for example that measuring
the snoring or the bracing
but there are limited many for sleep
apnea
and all the other 40 different Sleep
disorders
like insomnia narcolepsy RBD restless
leg Signum and many other
and actually many other sleep-related
disorder we know it's also relevant for
depression anxiety all kind of Neurology
disorder and so on all of them in order
to test it you need to have a sleep
study in clinic and we provide a tools
that could replace it and give you an
option to replace all this test from
your own bed
so this mainly is this coming you know
the selling point of the consumers is
coming from you know Doctors Hospitals
clinics how how do you see this at the
end making its way to the people's homes
it's it's a good question
from the beginning it was a
a question for us shall we approach it
from the
medical side or the Awana side because
when we talk about these tools that you
can use at home and you can use it both
for diagnosis but also for preventive
care
and you don't need to use it only once
but you can use it for a routine tests
then you there are several way to
approach it
so we had this debate from the beginning
of the company to decide which approach
will be better for us because from one
hand
we have a very high quality signal that
comparable to the medical rate
if this is from one side on the other
side we have a very I will call it sexy
electrodes with very unique form factors
that you can walk and thin very cool
with them and very good and you can use
it for several days in a row so we have
all kind of components that could be
really really relevant for Consumer as
well
so we had this debate at the end we
decided that we bring
an advantage with the signal quantity
the the medical Rim actually needs and
we decided to start with the medical
side so we are in a process with FDA
we will provide it through hospitals and
Physicians with prescription
and we believe that once we will
establish our credibility and our tools
and so on we will consider uh have some
kind of a subset of the product or some
consumer version and so on in the future
sure but we decided to start through the
medical seat at the beginning
totally so if you're looking at a vision
or a company like this since you're
laying out sort of the framework both
from a from a research perspective but
also from a market penetration
perspective or Partnerships perspective
what does what is a vision like this
look like for a company like extrodes
so
first of all we would like to penetrate
to the medical field
and our first application is flip
so we would like to bring a full PSG in
the polynography for home use
with the regulatory approval and
reimbursement and all is needed in order
to have success in the medical field
from this point I I believe that there
are two directions that we can expand it
actually three first of all within the
field of sleep I believe that these
fields are so many hidden
uh
hints or not hints I would say it like a
gems for understanding our health so I
believe that if today we use slit mainly
for diagnosis I believe there are so
many other places we can expand we sleep
both treatment and treatment management
and preventive curves I think first
approach is to expand what you do during
sleep and once you start measuring on
not only one night yeah but you can do
it several nights and you can use it
every week every month and so on you
open new
boundaries in the feed of slipper the
second direction is like I mentioned
before it's to to approach beyond the
medical and go to the consumer so we'll
get the credibility and then to provide
solutions that everybody can buy it from
Amazon and you can have it right for
your own use without subscription
and the third direction is once we
demonstrate our ability in the field of
snips and we can explore other medical
things that we can expand to so I think
these are the three potential direction
for us as part of our vision
but uh sorry I just want to add last
point for me what is so exciting with
what we do in extrod is the fact that
there are more than 100 clinical
applications that use electrophysiology
today within the health system in the
U.S health system
we believe that our platform
could bring most of them
into our hold
make them
accessible outside the clinic
so I think the potential of such a
platform is is amazing
what excites you most from the different
verticals that you've mentioned you sort
of answer this now but I want to dive a
little bit deeper to understand your
personal motivations and aspirations
so for me first of all I really like the
speed of sleep
I think that you heard it before I think
that in the next few years it will
improve our way to diagnose and treat
all of us so and I think you know the
statistic talks about 30 percent of the
world population suffer from some kind
of a skin disorder
from my point of view with all the
people that I talked with I think it's
much higher and I think that many many
people suffer from a
Disorder so I do believe that this field
is is amazing field and there are so
much that we can do in the field so I
feel that
we know that it's important stage of our
life
we know that they're
so many that we can do through our sleep
both for diagnosis and treatment but we
are lacking good health and the fact
that we bring this kind of food for me
it's super exciting and if I would get
into more like the technical part I'm
really excited from the data so yes we
have super cool sensors that give us
information that and data quantities
that are not available
from people from a
environment and timing and all kind of
places that it was inaccessible until
today
and the fact that there are so
many readers that we can decipher from
this data for me it's it this is a wall
and we we are just the beginning of this
journey there's so much to do and we are
getting closer and closer
have you always been this passionate
about League specifically or bringing
these uh you know these new Innovations
to life and at the end to Consumers
hands
you know it
I think I could say no and yes
no because
every several years I have something
different that I fall find intriguing
for me so it started with Consciousness
and then the mystery of the brain and
now sleep
but I think when so it's three different
domain but I do think there is something
common when I tried to think about it
because I'm interested in in our sauce
in our Inner Space in our fact to have a
better life to improve our life quality
well-being understand ourselves and and
I think that
yes sleep is another very unique stage
of our
Consciousness in our brain in our health
that we can do so much within so I like
this mystery
I like the fact that I feel that it's
still you know
there are so much to explore in this
field
so I I like it
very very cool ziv thank you so much for
coming and sharing a what you're
obviously so excited about and so
important in the end I'm excited to to
to to see where you're taking extroads
and and how you're gonna make a
significant impact through research and
application and also on the applicative
side over the next few years so thank
you very very much and best of luck and
and I'm gonna be chewing from the side
thank you thank you
[Music]